naomi is in Walla Walla Washington hi
Naomi how are you hi babe I'm great
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up I want to know how to challenge a
bill from an AC company and someone came
to your home and did work oh yes sort of
if you could call it that well that was
that was the proposal anyway okay yeah
yeah so they didn't do the job
no okay and you talked to him about it
um yes and no they were supposed to come
out and do a diagnostic test on her air
conditioning unit for a home that we
recently purchased in I was expressly
explained that they would only charge
$69 until a diagnostic was reached and I
asked them each time they arrived at my
house okay am I getting charged for this
so I need to include this in my budget
and he said no no we're just doing a
diagnostic and once we see without the
diagnostic we'll sit down with you and
tell you the breakdown of the charges
we never got me a diagnostic and I
waited for several weeks and it's a new
town that we lived in and so I called my
realtor and asked for a reliable
resource you're an AC company and within
two days I had a new company out and
they fix their unit for $500 and during
this time I got a call back from the old
AC company saying that their estimated
cost would be $1,200 and so I told them
that you know I'd tear a diagnostic she
but that we chose to go with another
company well then I get a bill in the
mail for two hundred and seventy dollars
I would call them up and say listen I
you know I had you out to do a
diagnostic you never even provided the
diagnostic but I'll pay the $69 and you
need to waive the rest of this if you
don't I am going to turn you in to the
Better Business Bureau I'm going to file
suit against you I'm gonna call the
local news and let them know and I'm
gonna cause you all kinds of hell you
did not do $250 worth of work out here
you are not authorized to do any work
beyond $69 and I'll not be paying a dime
above that okay so I don't need to put
it in letter form I don't even do that
follow up and you know and say when you
send me a note saying the total amount
owed is $69 you can send it by email or
snail mail either one I will send you a
check for 69 dollars you'll not be
getting any more than that from me and
you will be getting trouble from me if
you don't write this account down to
this because you were not authorized to
do a dime above this and you think
you're scamming me you're confused okay
and everybody we meet is going to know
about you if you misbehave further here
okay and so these guys what they do that
there are two kinds of people in the
heating and air business that work
directly with the consumer like you and
these situations both have a diagnostic
fee a matter of fact I just put a check
in the mail for 69 bucks this morning to
my heating and air company for a
diagnostic they came out that we asked
them to come out we had a unit frozen up
they came out told us what it was and
that you know it was three dollars or
more to fix it so they fixed it while
they were there because I do a lot of
work for us it was all fine right that's
a legitimate thing where they just are
getting basically a trip charge is what
it is to come out and do the labor to
see what's going on the other kind of
company which is what you're dealing
with this crooked company here is uses
the diagnostic as a bait-and-switch they
use the diagnostic as a way to get in
and then propose ridiculous levels of
repairs that are beyond what are needed
and we know that's true here because
what they propose $1200 for you were
able to do for five hundred less than a
half mm-hmm and so you know you're
dealing with people here they don't have
ethics and so I'm gonna be nice the
first phone call if it doesn't work I'm
gonna go all the way up the food chain
to the owner and I am going to wear
somebody out over 250 bucks here so one
question for you is the AC guy that came
the nice gentleman she said that a lot
of people in this town have had major
issues and I actually found a court but
they end up pain because this company
gives them hell and threatens them and
all that was I mean no side how
hillbilly you want to go on them I mean
okay well I want to stick it to them but
at the same time too
you isn't that me getting a lawyer and
that coffee no yeah yeah you're gonna
depends on how far you want to take this
you know but uh you know there you know
we can we can jump on Facebook we can
jump on Twitter we can let every real
estate agent and company in County in
town know I mean I can jack you up and
Jack you around I'll make you or me life
miserable my turn $50 hobby out of you
people you know and you know you just
decide how far you want to take it but
um you know obviously this company makes
a living pushing people around rather
than serving people and as far as I'm
concerned these the kind of people
she'll be run out of business I agree
and they give capitalism a bad name you
know and so the good news this is you
have the right to tell everybody you
know and the obligation to tell them to
stay away from these guys so it's too
sad to sent hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind